What’s good homeboy?
This week we divin down da rabbit hole with "Alice in Wonderland" by Lewis Carrol.
Alice chillin wit her sista and is ready to pass da f**k out when girl peep a swagged-out rabbit
yappin bout how late he gon’ be. Whaaat?
Alice follow dis busta down a rabbit hole, falls fo a long ass time, and end up in a hall with a buncha locked doors.
Alice find a baby size key dat fits a baby size door, open dat bitch up, and peeps a fine-ass garden on da otha side.
Problem is, Alice too damn thick to
get through.
She spots a little cup o’ drank, give it a sip, and turns into an itty biddy.
Oh sh*t! Now she can’t use dat baby size key!
So then she peep a piece of cake dat say “EAT ME." Girl get her grub on, and ends up hella big.
Since she still cain’t fit through da door, she start cryin and straight up floods da whole damn room.
Girl picks up a fan, gets small again, and now she flowin in dat river o’ tears.
After swimmin to safety and chillin wit some animal homies, Alice sees dat white rabbit again.
Fool roll up on Alice thinkin she his servant and tell her to get her ass back home.
Eventually, Alice truck it to da forest where she peep a giant Caterpillar chillin on a shroom chiefin some dank.
Brotha give her the 411 on how this shroom work — one side make her big, the other side makes her small.
Later, Alice peep some cat chillin in a tree with a sh*t-eating grin all up on his mug.
Fool’s name is Cheshire Cat, and he give her directions to the March Hare’s party.
Aw, hell yeah, CRISTAL B*TCHES!
Up at da March Hare’s spot, Alice joins a tea party wit some otha hustlas: Da Mad Hatter and a sleepy ass mouse.
Da Hatter say they ain’t neva gon' stop sippin on da tea cuz fo them, it’s always 6pm.
Time dun lost his damn mind.
Alice throw up tha deuce and cruises over to dat sweet garden she peeped at tha beginning.
She runs up on da baddest bitch in da hood — Da Queen of Hearts.
Girl wanna cut off everybody’s head fo no damn reason!
Da Queen even accuse da Knave of Hearts of stealin some of her grub and puts his ass on trial.
Alice take part fo a little while and finally say, “Hold up! Dat’s some bullsh*t right there.”
Da Queen tell her to shut her damn face, but Alice like, “Bitch hop off my nuts. You just a pack of cards.”
Tired of her stupid lip, da Queen try to ice Alice by smackin her round.
Then SNAP —Alice wake up in her sister’s lap.
Damn. What the hell was dis girl smokin...
...and where can I get some?
Lewis Carol wasn’t like most writers. First of all, dat ain’t even his real name.
His mama called him Charles Lutwidge Dodgson.
And second, playa got mad game at logic
and mathematics.
Matta fact, years of slingin dat logic influenced da comedy up in dis book,
like when da Queen and her posse arguing about cutting of da Cheshire Cat’s head.
Da real joke come from what it actually mean to behead somethin
and whether or not you can do somethin you ain’t understand:
"The executioner's argument was, that you couldn't cut off a head unless there was a body to cut it off from:
that he had never had to do such a thing before, and he wasn't going to begin at his time of life.
The King's argument was that anything that had a head could be beheaded, and that you weren't to talk nonsense."
The Queen's argument was that, if something wasn't done about it in less than no time,
she'd have everybody executed, all round."
Homies got all sortsa readings fo dis book.
Some say dat we peepin legit dreams dat representin all da crunk and creepy sh*t Carrol got goin on in his dome.
Otha scholars think all dis wackness is just a way to philosophize in a real artistic way.
Maybe dat hard logic been applied to a crazy world just tryna make a bigger point:
dat every hustla tryna find order in their life, but da world around em ain’t nuthin but chaos.
This whole wonderland is batsh*t crazy —
we got objects giving order to people, and we got time stopping like some type of lazy piece of sh**.
But da world ain’t da only thing that's changin — we changin too, 24/7.
All throughout dis book, Alice always tryna define herself
and flippin sh*t cuz she cain’t pin nuthin down — even who she is.
'Dear, dear! How queer everything is to-day! And yesterday things went on just as usual.
I wonder if I've changed in the night? Let me think: was I the same when I got up this morning?
I almost think I can remember feeling a little different.
But if I'm not the same, the next question is 'Who in the world am I?' Ah, that's the great puzzle!''
Truth is, we all a little like Alice in Wonderland — we grow, we shrink, we learn.
Erry day we forced to confront a world dat look like it’s upside down,
and all the while, we changin so much dat we can lose track of who we are if we ain’t payin attention.
Dat ain’t an easy pill to swallow, yo.
So follow da white rabbit back to my store and cop yoself some Thug Notes Gear. Peace padna!